So you may have noticed that I haven't actually taught you much of anything new
yet. All this is really just a new notation for manipulating different kinds of
expressions. However, this new notation gives us an important way to think
about functions. Just like variables can be added, subtracted, multiplied and
divided, so can functions. In fact, there's an even shorter, easier way of
representing things like f of x plus g of x, or any of the other things I have
written down here. Let me show you. And, this is all it is. If we want to add
two functions, f and g, and of course they're dealing with the same variable,
which in this case is x. Then we just write in parentheses, f plus g, showing
that they're one combined function when we add them together like this. So we
have f plus g of x. Similarly, for subtraction, we can have f minus g of x. For
multiplication we just multiply f and g together inside the first parentheses,
and for division, we do the same thing with dividing. If we have the functions
f of x equals x, and g of x equals x squared minus x, then please tell me what
we get for each of these combined functions down here.